very quickly it is Oscars weekend this
weekend and there Ian would you mind
telling us the story about when you were
nominated for Gandalf seminary and you
had the the beads yeah
well there weren't beats the in New
Zealand where we filmed Lord the Rings
[Applause]
if you're lucky when you leave you're
given a piece of green stone carved and
you wear it often enough and your
chances out you'll get back to New
Zealand that's the idea and it'll bring
you a bit of luck
so when those films were nominated with
something like 20 Oscars on that night
everybody from New Zealand was wearing
the green stone that
Pournami they're caught and run we're on
the red carpet going into the certainly
I met Maggie Smith you know what our
union what are you here for
I said well Lord of the Rings oh yeah
she said what's that around your neck no
sir it's my phone on me maybe I only owe
punar me once that if I said well if I
wear it it will bring me luck and and we
went our separate ways and unit lasts
for three and a half or four hours you
know and at the end of course everyone
else wins the Oscar apart from you and a
bit dejected you're coming out looking
forward to drinking you bump into Maggie
Smith and she points out it didn't work
[Applause]
graham norton air if you'd like to see
even more stuff like that that hit
subscribe or don't it's a free world but
I know what I do in that situation